- Bine ai revenit la Înțelegerea
Informației și Computației Cuantice.
Numele meu este John Watrous și sunt directorul tehnic
pentru IBM Quantum Education.
Aceasta este a treia lecție a seriei. În primele două lecții, am vorbit despre bazele
informației cuantice.
Mai întâi pentru sisteme individuale izolate, apoi pentru sisteme multiple.
Am discutat, de asemenea, măsurătorile în
baza standard și operațiile unitare atât în contextul
unui singur sistem, cât și în cel al sistemelor multiple.
În această lecție, vom introduce
modelul circuit cuantic, care ne oferă o modalitate standard de a descrie computațiile cuantice,
și putem folosi circuit-urile cuantice și pentru a descrie protocoale cuantice și alte tipuri de interacțiuni ce implică mai multe dispozitive cuantice.
Pe lângă circuit-urile cuantice, vom discuta și câteva
concepte matematice importante legate de informația cuantică,
și le vom folosi pentru a observa
câteva limitări fundamentale ale informației cuantice și ce putem face cu circuit-urile cuantice.
Asta ne va pregăti bine pentru
lecția următoare, unde vom vedea câteva
exemple foarte importante, și cu asta vom încheia
prima unitate a seriei
despre bazele informației cuantice.
Iată o prezentare generală a lecției. Vom începe cu modelul circuit cuantic și vom vedea cum funcționează.
Apoi vom vorbi despre
noțiunea extrem de importantă de produs intern, precum și despre ortonormalitate și proiecții,
care sunt legate de produsele interne. Nu am discutat aceste lucruri
în primele două lecții, deoarece nu
aveam nevoie de ele, dar acum avem.
Produsele interne ne oferă
un instrument matematic fără de care pur și simplu nu am putea trece mai departe.
Nu am avansa deloc în înțelegerea informației
și computației cuantice fără produse interne.
Iar în a treia parte a lecției, vom analiza câteva
limitări importante ale informației cuantice.
În esență, vrem să explorăm lucruri
interesante pe care le putem face cu informația cuantică, dar pentru a face asta eficient,
trebuie să fim conștienți de unele
lucruri pe care nu le putem face.
În special, vom discuta
noțiunea de fază globală și de ce fazele globale sunt irelevante.
Vom vedea o formulare a
teoremei no-cloning, care ne spune că stările cuantice nu pot fi copiate în general, și vom vedea că două stări cuantice
nu pot fi
discriminate perfect una de cealaltă dacă nu sunt ortogonale, ceea ce reprezintă o limitare
fundamentală de care trebuie să fii conștient.
Primul subiect al lecției
este modelul circuit cuantic, care este un model de computație
ce ne oferă o modalitate
de a descrie computații cuantice.
Modelul circuit cuantic se
bazează pe o noțiune mai generală din informatică, aceea de circuit, și poți defini multe
modele diferite de computație
bazate pe această noțiune generală.
Ideea de bază este că un
circuit este compus din fire care transportă informații și gate-uri care reprezintă operații
aplicate
informației transportate de fire.
Termenul circuit este de fapt
un nume cam ciudat pentru acest tip de model,
deoarece cuvântul circuit
se referă de obicei la un
traseu circular de un fel sau altul.
Dar când vorbim despre circuit-uri
ca modele de computație, ne referim de obicei
la circuit-uri aciclice
în care traseele circulare nu sunt permise.
Mai precis, pentru
scopurile acestei serii, vom cere ca
informația să curgă întotdeauna de la stânga la dreapta în orice circuit.
Deci, dacă preferi, poți
să te gândești la circuit-uri ca la descrieri ale unor secvențe de operații în care timpul merge de la stânga la dreapta.
Iată un exemplu de circuit Boolean în care firele transportă
valori binare, fie zero, fie unu,
iar gate-urile reprezintă
operații de logică booleană.
Firele sunt reprezentate prin linii, iar aici avem doi biți de intrare
etichetați X și Y,
și dacă vrem să știm
ce face circuit-ul pentru o anumită alegere de intrări, propagăm valorile pe
fire de la stânga la dreapta,
în funcție de acțiunile
pe care gate-urile le au asupra valorilor
transportate de fire.
Deci, de exemplu, putem
să vedem ce se întâmplă când pornim cu firul de intrare de sus setat la valoarea unu și cu firul de intrare de jos
setat la valoarea zero.
Aceste două fire de intrare duc
în aceste două puncte de aici, care reprezintă operații de fan-out, ceea ce înseamnă că valoarea este copiată
astfel încât să poată fi transmisă
mai departe prin mai multe fire.
Deci, dacă facem asta, atunci aceste
două fire iau valoarea unu, care este aceeași cu unu, iar aceste două fire iau valoarea zero,
care este aceeași cu zero.
Aici avem un gate NOT care
este indicat prin simbolul pentru negare logică, deci
valoarea care iese este zero,
care este negarea logică a lui unu. Și similar, valoarea
care iese din acest gate este unu, care este
negarea logică a lui zero.
Aceste două gate-uri sunt gate-uri AND,
acesta este un gate OR, și dacă continuăm
și propagăm valorile
WEBVTT
prin circuit, evaluând
gate-urile corespunzător, vedem că valoarea finală
pe acest fir de aici este unu.
Deci, întregul circuit descrie
o secvență de operații compuse așa cum sugerează figura, și obținem o funcție
de la doi biți la un bit
în acest caz particular. Dar în general, poate exista orice număr
de biți de intrare și de ieșire.
Acest circuit particular calculează XOR-ul exclusiv al celor doi biți de intrare, deci ieșirea este unu
dacă și numai dacă exact
unul dintre cei doi biți de intrare este setat la unu și celălalt este setat la zero, dar asta nu este
cu adevărat important, este doar un exemplu.
Este un fapt de bază despre circuit-urile Booleene că orice funcție de la orice număr de biți la orice număr de biți poate fi calculată
de un circuit Boolean, deși uneori
ai putea avea nevoie de un circuit foarte mare pentru a calcula funcția
care te interesează.
Există și alte stiluri care
sunt folosite pentru a descrie circuit-urile.
De exemplu, această figură
reprezintă exact același circuit ca cel de mai înainte, folosind un stil poate mai tipic
în ingineria electrică, unde există convenții pentru formele ce reprezintă diferite gate-uri.
Nu vom folosi
acest stil particular, dar vom introduce
câteva simboluri proprii pentru diferite gate-uri cuantice, cum ar fi gate-urile Hadamard,
gate-urile Controlled NOT,
gate-urile Toffoli și altele.
Ca notă secundară, aici putem vedea originea
termenului circuit.
În contextul ingineriei electrice, este foarte natural să
ne gândim la electricitate care circulă prin un circuit.
Dar în această serie nu
vorbim despre electricitate care se mișcă prin circuit-uri, vorbim despre informație
care se mișcă prin circuit-uri.
Și din nou pentru noi, acestea vor fi întotdeauna aciclice, cu informația
care se mișcă de la stânga la dreapta.
Iată un exemplu diferit de
un alt tip de circuit, numit circuit aritmetic.
De această dată, firele stochează numere, iar gate-urile reprezintă
operații aritmetice cum ar fi adunarea și înmulțirea.
Aici poți vedea un exemplu
de circuit aritmetic.
Nu este important pentru
această lecție ce face, este doar un exemplu menit
să transmită ideea că există diferite
noțiuni de circuit-uri.
Ne putem gândi și la
circuit-uri care implică aleatorizare, de exemplu, unde gate-urile reprezintă
operații probabiliste, și dacă ai chef,
ai putea sta probabil toată ziua visând la noi modele de computație bazate pe noțiunea de circuit-uri.
În modelul circuit cuantic,
firele reprezintă qubit-uri, iar gate-urile reprezintă atât operații unitare, cât și măsurători.
Iată un exemplu foarte simplu
de circuit cuantic.
Există un singur qubit în acest circuit, care este reprezentat
prin linia orizontală, iar gate-urile, indicate prin pătrate,
reprezintă operații unitare efectuate pe acest qubit.
Deci nu există măsurători
în acest exemplu particular.
Dacă vrem să dăm
qubit-ului un nume cum ar fi X, putem indica asta în diagramă punând un X chiar
aici, ceea ce este opțional.
La fel ca în cazul circuit-ului Boolean de acum câteva momente, ne putem gândi la acest circuit
ca reprezentând o secvență de operații în care timpul
merge de la stânga la dreapta.
Deci pornim cu X,
aplicăm primul gate, care este un gate Hadamard
urmat de un gate S,
apoi un alt gate Hadamard
și în final un gate T.
Am văzut aceste operații
spre sfârșitul lecției unu, și aici poți vedea
descrierile lor matriceale.
Deci când efectuăm aceste
patru operații în ordine, adică mai întâi H, apoi
S, apoi H din nou, și apoi T,
operația combinată este dată
de acest produs de aici, ținând cont că ordinea
se inversează practic
cum am discutat în lecția unu. Dacă efectuăm înmulțirea matriceală, obținem această matrice de aici,
și deci acțiunea circuit-ului
asupra qubit-ului X este descrisă de această matrice unitară.
Uneori vrem să indicăm explicit într-o diagramă de circuit cuantic
ce intrare furnizăm, și putem face asta cum vezi chiar aici.
În acest caz, introducem
Ket 0 în circuit.
Este destul de obișnuit. Luăm adesea Ket 0 ca
stare inițializată a unui qubit, dar asta nu este obligatoriu.
Am putea lua în considerare și
aplicarea circuit-ului la o stare diferită.
Dacă alegem, putem, de asemenea,
indica starea de ieșire pe care o obținem, ca în exemplul acesta.
Iată un alt exemplu în care
de această dată avem două qubit-uri numite X și Y, cum
poți vedea în diagramă.
Avem un gate Hadamard, care este aplicat qubit-ului Y, urmat de gate-ul indicat prin
acest simbol de aici,
care este un gate Controlled NOT. Am vorbit despre
operația Controlled NOT în lecția anterioară,
și în această diagramă putem
vedea că qubit-ul de control este Y, indicat prin
cercul mic plin,
iar qubit-ul țintă este X, indicat prin cercul mare cu ceva ce arată ca un semn plus în el.
Seamănă oarecum cu
simbolul pentru XOR exclusiv, deci are sens.
WEBVTT
Îți poți imagina că orice
stare clasică stocată în Y este aplicată XOR pe qubit-ul X.
Și doar pentru claritate, iată diagrama care
arată acțiunea acestui gate pe stările bazei standard,
unde presupunem că A
și B sunt valori binare.
Pentru alte stări, acțiunea este determinată
prin liniaritate, ca de obicei.
Acum, înainte de a continua, va fi util să
formulăm explicit o convenție pe care o vom urma privind modul în care qubit-urile sunt ordonate
în diagrame de circuit cuantic ca aceasta.
Convenția este că
ordonarea de jos în sus într-o diagramă de circuit cuantic este echivalentă cu ordonarea de la stânga la dreapta
ca într-un tuplu sau un produs tensorial.
Aceasta este o convenție pe care o vom
urma în serie și este, de asemenea, convenția
folosită în Qiskit.
Deci pentru acest circuit particular, ne gândim la el ca
acționând pe o pereche de qubit-uri X, Y,
X vine primul deoarece este în partea de jos, iar Y vine ultimul sau al doilea în acest caz, deoarece este în partea de sus.
Modul în care îți poți imagina asta
vizual, în caz că ajută, este să îți imaginezi că
rotești acest circuit în sensul acelor de ceasornic, astfel încât intrările să fie în sus
și ieșirile în jos, și ordinea
qubit-urilor va fi corectă.
Uneori această ordine îi încurcă pe oameni, deci asigură-te că ții
minte această convenție.
Deci când ne gândim la acțiunea descrisă de acest circuit, avem mai întâi un
gate Hadamard aplicat lui Y
și apoi un gate Controlled NOT
pe cele două qubit-uri, cu Y ca control
și X ca țintă.
Dacă vrem să scriem o matrice unitară care descrie acțiunea combinată
a acestor două gate-uri, putem face asta.
Mai întâi, considerăm gate-ul Hadamard pe Y.
Aplicăm gate-ul Hadamard pe Y și nu facem nimic cu X, ceea ce este echivalent cu
efectuarea unei operații identitate pe X.
Deci acțiunea gate-ului Hadamard pe ambele qubit-uri împreună este
dată de produsul tensorial al matricei identitate și
al matricei care reprezintă
operația Hadamard pe Y.
Arată astfel, ținând cont de
convenția noastră că X vine primul și Y vine al doilea, deci este
identitatea tensorată cu H.
Apoi aplicăm
operația Controlled NOT, care are această
reprezentare matriceală, și din nou, asta este consistent cu convenția noastră.
Al doilea qubit Y este controlul, iar primul qubit X este ținta.
Nu-ți fie teamă să pauzi videoclipul și să verifici că are sens, și o să mă opresc să îți mai amintesc asta.
Poți pauza aceste videoclipuri, te poți întoarce și viziona părți
de câte ori vrei, poți ajusta viteza de redare dacă alegi, le poți folosi în orice
mod care ți se potrivește cel mai bine.
Oricum, când combinăm
cele două operații, acțiunea combinată este descrisă
de acest produs de aici,
iar aceste două matrice sunt
înmulțite în această ordine deoarece Hadamard este efectuat primul și Controlled NOT
este efectuat al doilea,
și din nou, asta este consistent
cu ce am discutat în lecția unu, unde ordinea
se inversează practic.
Dacă efectuăm înmulțirea matriceală, obținem această matrice de aici.
Și acum putem citi din această matrice ce face circuit-ul cu
stările bazei standard.
Dacă rulăm circuit-ul pe intrarea 0, 0, adică Ket 0 pentru primul qubit, Ket 0 pentru al doilea qubit,
rezultatul este starea Bell Phi+, pe care o putem vedea din
prima coloană a matricei.
Dacă introducem 0, 1, obținem starea Phi-, unu zero ne dă starea Psi+,
iar 1, 1 ne dă nu Psi-, ci -1 x Psi-.
Semnul minus nu este
cu adevărat semnificativ aici. Dacă nu ai vrea să fie aici, ai putea efectua o operație swap
pe cele două qubit-uri
pentru a scăpa de el și
nu ai strica ce s-a întâmplat cu primele trei stări ale bazei standard.
Dar chiar nu este important
pentru scopul acestui exemplu.
Deci, în rezumat, circuit-ul are această acțiune de aici pe stările bazei standard.
Când te gândești la
ce face un anumit circuit, nu trebuie să treci prin
conversia la matrice și să le înmulțești,
poți, de asemenea, să urmărești
acțiunea pe care circuit-ul o are pe stări particulare, și în multe cazuri aceasta va fi
opțiunea preferată.
În acest exemplu, de pildă, putem vedea ce face circuit-ul
cu starea 0, 0 examinând acțiunea gate-urilor.
Starea inițială, pe care
am numit-o Pi zero aici, doar pentru a evita un nume
care ar putea fi confundat cu stările Bell, este 0, 0.
Aplicăm gate-ul Hadamard și starea pe care o obținem este 0+, pe care o putem extinde astfel,
iar operația Controlled NOT duce această stare la starea Phi+, pe care o putem vedea gândindu-ne
la acțiunea pe care Controlled NOT o are asupra
stărilor bazei standard,
iar tu poți face același lucru
pentru celelalte trei stări ale bazei standard sau pentru orice
altă stare.
Putem, de asemenea, incorpora biți clasici în diagramele de circuit cuantic.
Aceștia sunt indicați prin
linii duble cum vezi în această diagramă.
Adică A și B sunt biți clasici, iar X și Y sunt qubit-uri.
WEBVTT
Avem aceleași două gate-uri unitare ca în exemplul anterior, iar aceste simboluri de aici reprezintă măsurători în baza standard
Mai precis, după ce
cele două operații unitare sunt efectuate, o măsurătoare în baza standard
este efectuată pe Y
iar rezultatul este suprascris
în bitul clasic B, și similar X este măsurat, iar rezultatul este scris în bitul A.
Aici poți vedea că qubit-urile X și Y continuă după ce sunt măsurate.
Este destul de obișnuit
totuși că nu ne pasă prea mult de qubit-uri
după ce sunt măsurate.
Uneori ne interesează doar
rezultatul măsurătorii. Și în un astfel de caz, putem folosi stilul prescurtat
pe care îl vezi aici
unde măsurătorile au qubit-uri intrând și biți clasici ieșind.
Înțelegerea aici este că
odată ce qubit-urile sunt măsurate, sunt pur și simplu aruncate sau ignorate, iar rezultatul clasic al măsurătorii
este dus mai departe.
Acum, pe măsură ce seria continuă, vom vedea multe
exemple de circuit-uri cuantice, care de obicei
vor fi mult mai complicate decât exemplele foarte simple
pe care tocmai le-am văzut.
Cum am menționat mai devreme, simboluri diferite sunt
folosite pentru gate-uri diferite.
Gate-urile cu un singur qubit sunt de obicei
scrise ca pătrate cu o literă indicând
ce operație este.
Uneori aceste gate-uri diferite
sunt codificate cu culori pentru a semnifica lucruri diferite, dar
vom ignora asta deocamdată.
Am văzut deja
gate-ul Controlled NOT.
Gate-urile Swap sunt notate
cum vezi chiar aici, iar gate-urile Toffoli și Fredkin
sunt notate cum vezi chiar aici.
Ține minte că un gate Toffoli este un gate Controlled NOT controlat, iar un gate Fredkin este
un gate swap controlat.
Deci aceste simboluri sunt
consistente cu ideea că un qubit de control este
indicat printr-un cerc plin cu o linie care îl conectează
la gate-ul pe care îl controlează.
În general, qubit-urile controlate
nu trebuie să fie în sus, iar aceste gate-uri nu trebuie
să acționeze pe qubit-uri vecine, ceea ce înseamnă că aceste gate-uri
pot fi extinse peste
alte qubit-uri pe care nu acționează, și vom vedea asta
întâmplându-se în lecțiile viitoare.
Încă un lucru pe care îl facem adesea când folosim modelul circuit cuantic este să privim operații unitare arbitrare
pe orice număr de qubit-uri
ca și cum ar fi gate-uri individuale, cum vezi chiar aici.
Pur și simplu desenând un dreptunghi cu o etichetă corespunzătoare
oricărei operații unitare este.
În acest caz este
o operație unitară U.
Bineînțeles, nu știm
ce este U din această diagramă, trebuie să presupunem că
U este definit cumva sau că luăm în considerare ceva arbitrar
operație unitară U, poate. Ar putea fi, de exemplu, că
vrem să ne gândim la U ca la o subrutină
în interesul clarității.
Folosim, de asemenea, această notație
pe care o vezi chiar aici pentru o operație U controlată
în care qubit-ul de control este indicat printr-un cerc plin
exact cum aveam înainte.
Deci aceasta a fost o scurtă introducere
în modelul circuit cuantic. Și cum am spus înainte, vom vedea multe mai multe
exemple de circuit-uri cuantice
pe măsură ce continuăm în serie.
În următoarea parte a lecției, vom analiza
produse interne, ortonormalitate și proiecții, care sunt noțiuni foarte importante
în informația și computația cuantică.
Vom începe cu produsele interne.
Ține minte că atunci când
folosim notația Dirac, un Ket este un vector coloană
iar un Bra este un vector linie,
și mai precis
vectorul Bra corespunzător unui vector coloană dat este transpusa conjugată
a acelui vector coloană.
Deci pentru acest vector de aici, obținem vectorul Bra corespunzător transponând vectorul
ca și cum ar fi o matrice,
ceea ce înseamnă să îl culcăm pe o parte și apoi să luăm conjugata complexă a fiecărui element.
Acum, să presupunem că avem două Ket-uri cu același număr de elemente, ca acesta.
Dacă formăm acest bracket de aici, care înseamnă pur și simplu că
luăm produsul Bra-ului și Ket-ului,
ca și cum ar fi matrice,
atunci obținem această expresie
pe care o vezi chiar aici, care este un scalar, sau cu alte
cuvinte un număr complex.
Această valoare se numește produsul intern
al acestor doi vectori.
Te poți gândi la produsele interne și în termeni de vectori de
forma pe care o vezi chiar aici, unde vectorii sunt exprimați
ca combinații liniare
de vectori ai bazei standard.
Produsul intern al acestor vectori este definit în același mod ca
înainte, Bra Psi înmulțit cu Ket Phi, pe care îl putem exprima
ca un produs ca acesta.
Și dacă calculăm și simplificăm, rămânem cu această expresie de aici pentru produsul intern, care este analogă cu ce aveam înainte,
cu excepția că de această dată
luăm suma peste elementele din mulțimea noastră de stări clasice, care este sigma în acest caz particular.
Iată un exemplu menit să îți dea o imagine geometrică pentru
modul în care funcționează produsele interne.
Aici am desenat un cerc
într-un spațiu bidimensional corespunzând unui qubit, și atâta timp cât ne limităm atenția
la vectori cu componente numere reale, îi putem desena ca puncte în acest plan.
WEBVTT
Să luăm Phi ca
acest vector de aici.
Este un vector unitar, pe care îl putem vedea
calculând norma euclidiană, și asta reprezintă acest cerc,
toți vectorii unitari
cu componente numere reale.
Să spunem că Psi este
acest vector de aici, care de asemenea este un vector unitar.
De fapt, este starea minus, dar aici îl numim doar Psi.
Dacă calculăm produsul intern
al acestor doi vectori, obținem unu minus rădăcina din trei peste doi înmulțit cu rădăcina din doi,
care este aproximativ -1/4.
Valoarea acestui produs intern este egală cu cosinusul unghiului
dintre cei doi vectori, pe care îl poți vedea în figură.
Asta este
adevărat în general pentru vectorii unitari. Dacă avem doi vectori unitari și ambii au componente numere reale,
atunci produsul intern dintre ei este egal cu cosinusul
unghiului dintre ei.
În special, dacă produsul intern
este egal cu zero, ca în acest exemplu, unde am schimbat Psi cu
această stare de aici,
atunci cei doi vectori trebuie
să fie la un unghi de 90 de grade unul față de celălalt.
Asta se generalizează la
vectori în orice dimensiune, de altfel, atâta timp cât
componentele sunt numere reale, nu este valabil doar pentru vectori bidimensionali.
Dacă avem componente de numere complexe, imaginea nu mai
funcționează chiar, dar cu toate acestea, produsul intern este la fel
de util, cum vom vedea.
Produsul intern are câteva
proprietăți foarte importante și vom lua câteva momente pentru a observa unele dintre acele proprietăți acum.
Prima este o legătură
între produsul intern și norma euclidiană.
Dacă luăm produsul intern
al oricărui vector cu el însuși, obținem norma euclidiană la pătrat.
Deci putem spune alternativ că norma euclidiană a unui vector este egală cu rădăcina pătrată a produsului intern
al acelui vector cu el însuși. Aceasta nu este o coincidență, este
o legătură fundamentală, și aici putem vedea că dacă nu am fi avut
conjugatele complexe în definiția produsului intern, atunci această formulă
nu ar mai fi adevărată, și nu am mai avea o noțiune atât de utilă
cu această legătură fundamentală
cu norma euclidiană.
Apoi, produsul intern
este conjugat-simetric, ceea ce înseamnă că dacă schimbăm
ordinea celor două argumente, valoarea pe care o obținem pentru
produsul intern se conjughează.
Asta este exprimat prin
această ecuație de aici și este destul de simplu de văzut de ce se întâmplă asta pentru aceste două expresii
ale produsului intern al celor doi vectori în cele două ordini posibile.
Produsul intern este liniar
în al doilea argument. Mai precis, dacă definim un vector Phi ca această combinație
liniară a doi vectori,
Phi unu și Phi doi, atunci produsul intern al
oricărui vector Psi cu Phi este aceeași combinație liniară
a celor două produse interne,
și asta urmează destul de
direct din faptul că înmulțirea matriceală este liniară.
Și avem de asemenea că produsul intern
este conjugat-liniar în primul argument, ceea ce poți vedea exprimat chiar aici.
Dacă Psi este această combinație
liniară de vectori, atunci dacă luăm produsul intern
al lui Psi și Phi,
atunci Bra Psi devine acest vector pe care îl vedem chiar aici, unde luăm conjugata complexă a lui beta unu și beta doi,
și deci acesta este rezultatul, și asta se înțelege
prin liniaritate conjugată.
Și ultima proprietate a produsului intern pe care vreau să o menționez este
inegalitatea Cauchy-Schwarz, incredibil de utilă.
Pentru orice doi vectori, Psi și Phi, valoarea absolută a produsului intern nu poate fi niciodată mai mare decât
produsul normelor euclidiene
ale celor doi vectori. Și mai mult, singura modalitate ca cele două
laturi ale inegalității să fie egale este dacă cei doi
vectori sunt liniar dependenți,
ceea ce înseamnă că unul dintre ei este egal cu un scalar înmulțit cu celălalt.
Aceasta este de fapt una dintre
cele mai frecvent folosite inegalități din toată matematica, și o folosim din nou și din nou când vorbim despre
informația cuantică,
deci este foarte bine să o cunoști.
Apoi, vom vorbi despre
noțiunile de ortogonalitate și ortonormalitate, care sunt
legate de produsele interne
și mai precis, de
produsele interne ale vectorilor egale cu zero.
Mai precis, dacă avem
doi vectori, Psi și Phi, spunem că sunt ortogonali
dacă produsul lor intern
este egal cu zero. Iar modul în care ne putem gândi
la vectorii ortogonali intuitiv este că sunt
în unghi drept unul față de celălalt,
sau alternativ, că sunt
perpendiculari unul față de celălalt.
Uneori oamenii folosesc termenul ortogonal pentru a se referi la lucruri care nu au
nimic în comun, cum ar fi să spui că o problemă
este ortogonală față de alta,
dar asta este evident destul de informal și nu cu adevărat semnificativ
din punct de vedere matematic, dar legătura este clară dacă te gândești la vectorii ortogonali ca indicând
nu în direcții opuse, ci în direcții complet diferite, cum ar fi nord față de vest, de exemplu.
Dacă avem un set de vectori, spunem că setul este un set ortogonal dacă oricare doi vectori distincți
aleși din acel set
sunt în mod necesar ortogonali unul față de celălalt, ceea ce putem exprima
cum vezi chiar aici,
WEBVTT
Un set ortonormal este
pur și simplu un set ortogonal de vectori unitari.
Vectorii din seturi ortogonale
nu trebuie neapărat să fie vectori unitari, și de fapt ai putea
chiar să ai vectorul zero
ca element al unui set ortogonal, dar într-un set ortonormal, fiecare vector trebuie să fie un vector unitar
pe lângă
cerința că setul este un set ortogonal.
Dată fiind cunoașterea noastră despre relația dintre produsul intern
și norma euclidiană, putem exprima această
condiție destul de succint
cum vezi chiar aici.
Și în final, o bază ortonormală este pur și simplu un set ortonormal
care formează o bază pentru orice spațiu vectorial
despre care vorbim.
De exemplu, dacă luăm orice
mulțime de stări clasice sigma și ne gândim la setul tuturor
vectorilor bazei standard,
vedem că acesta este un set ortonormal și de fapt este o bază ortonormală pentru spațiul tuturor vectorilor ale căror componente corespund
acestei mulțimi de stări clasice sigma.
Aceștia sunt toți vectori unitari și
sunt ortogonali în perechi, deci este un set ortonormal.
și deoarece este și o bază, avem că este o bază ortonormală.
Seturile ortonormale sunt
întotdeauna liniar independente, de altfel, deci de câte ori
ai un set ortonormal, va fi întotdeauna o bază ortonormală pentru un anumit subspațiu,
dar în acest caz, avem o bază pentru întregul spațiu cu care lucrăm.
Un alt exemplu este setul
care conține Ket+ și Ket-.
Acești doi vectori sunt ortogonali, produsul lor intern este egal cu zero.
și sunt ambii vectori unitari și acoperă
spațiul bidimensional al vectorilor corespunzând unui singur qubit, deci formează o bază ortonormală
pentru acel spațiu.
Un alt exemplu este baza Bell, care este o bază ortonormală pentru spațiul tuturor
vectorilor de dimensiune patru corespunzând la două qubit-uri.
Setul care conține Ket 0
și Ket+, pe de altă parte, nu este un set ortogonal deoarece produsul intern dintre
acești vectori este nenul.
Sunt ambii vectori unitari și acesta este o bază pentru spațiul vectorial corespunzând unui qubit, dar nu avem ortogonalitate.
Iată un fapt util despre seturile ortonormale pe care îl vom folosi din când în când.
Să presupunem că avem un
set ortonormal de vectori, mai precis, să presupunem
că avem M vectori în acest set, Psi unu până la Psi M,
unde presupunem că acești vectori provin dintr-un spațiu vectorial de dimensiune N, sau cu alte cuvinte, fiecare
dintre vectori are M componente.
Cum am menționat deja, seturile ortonormale sunt întotdeauna
liniar independente, deci nu se poate ca M să fie mai mare decât N,
dar se poate ca M să fie mai mic decât N, și acesta este cazul care
ne interesează.
Iar ce spune faptul este
că dacă M este mai mic decât N, atunci este întotdeauna posibil
să adăugăm vectori suplimentari
la setul cu care am început pentru a obține o
bază ortonormală pentru spațiul nostru.
Mai precis, trebuie
să existe în mod necesar vectori Psi M+1 până la Psi N astfel încât întreaga colecție
să formeze o bază ortonormală.
Deci nu te poți vreodată pica
într-un colț, ca să spunem așa, alegând un
set ortonormal de vectori care nu poate fi extins pentru
a forma o bază ortonormală.
Uneori poți să te uiți pur și simplu
la setul cu care începi și să dai seama cum să îl extinzi pentru a forma o bază ortonormală, dar o alternativă care funcționează întotdeauna
este să folosești o procedură cunoscută drept procesul de
ortonormalizare Gram-Schmidt pentru a construi acești vectori.
Nu voi explica acea
procedură în această lecție sau în această serie, deoarece specificul nu este
cu adevărat important pentru noi, dar bineînțeles că o poți căuta dacă ești curios.
Este ceva ce poate
fi efectuat de un calculator dacă asta este relevant, deci
nu implică nicio creativitate, este doar o procedură mecanică.
Unul dintre motivele pentru care acesta este
un fapt atât de util de avut este legat de o legătură strânsă care există între bazele
ortonormale și matricele unitare.
În particular, pentru orice matrice pătratică U, cele trei condiții pe care le vezi aici sunt întotdeauna echivalente,
adică sunt fie
toate adevărate, fie toate false.
Prima condiție spune
că U este o matrice unitară, ceea ce înseamnă că atât U dagger înmulțit cu U, cât și U înmulțit cu U dagger sunt ambele
egale cu matricea identitate.
A doua condiție
spune că rândurile lui U formează o bază ortonormală,
iar a treia condiție spune că coloanele lui U
formează o bază ortonormală.
De fapt, nu este prea greu
să vedem de ce această echivalență este adevărată.
Doar pentru a simplifica, să analizăm o
matrice trei pe trei U cum o vezi chiar aici, unde componentele pot fi orice
numere complexe dorești.
Aici în stânga am scris U transpusă conjugată
doar pentru comoditate.
Dacă formăm trei vectori
din coloanele lui U, care sunt denumite Psi
unu, Psi doi și Psi trei, atunci dacă luăm
produsul U dagger și U,
poți verifica că fiecare
componentă a produsului este dată de un produs intern al vectorilor cum vedem chiar aici în acest tipar.
Și acum când te gândești la condiția că U este unitar, care este echivalentă cu aceasta matrice egală cu matricea identitate,
vezi că este echivalentă
cu cei trei vectori care formează un set ortonormal.
Componentele diagonale trebuie toate
să fie egale cu unu, deci aceștia sunt în mod necesar vectori unitari, iar componentele de pe diagonala secundară trebuie să fie zero,
deci este un set ortogonal de vectori.
WEBVTT
Deci U fiind unitar este echivalent cu coloanele care formează un set ortonormal,
Și acesta trebuie să fie o bază deoarece numărul de vectori din set, care este trei în acest caz, corespunde cu dimensiunea spațiului
cu care lucrăm. Poți urma un argument similar pentru rânduri în loc de coloane pentru a concluziona că U este
unitar echivalent
cu rândurile care formează o bază ortonormală.
Nu funcționează chiar la fel de elegant deoarece trebuie să facem o ajustare pentru ca conjugatele complexe
să funcționeze în modul corect, dar ideea este aceeași.
O modalitate alternativă de a proceda, care este destul de simplă, este să dovedești că o matrice este unitară dacă și numai dacă transpusa ei este unitară.
Și aici chiar vreau să spun transpusă și nu transpusă conjugată.
Este destul de trivial din
definiția matricelor unitare că transpusa conjugată
a oricărei matrice unitare este unitară,
dar este de asemenea adevărat că transpusa oricărei matrice unitare este unitară.
În orice caz, avem
echivalența între aceste trei condiții pe orice matrice pătratică U, și putem combina această echivalență
cu faptul despre
extinderea seturilor ortonormale pentru a forma baze ortonormale, pentru a veni cu matrice unitare
care fac lucruri interesante
sau satisfac diverse nevoi pe care le putem întâlni.
Mai precis, de câte ori avem
un set ortonormal de M vectori, va exista întotdeauna o matrice unitară U
ale cărei prime M coloane sunt vectorii din acel set ortonormal.
Coloanele rămase
pot fi întotdeauna completate astfel încât să obținem o matrice unitară, alegând-le astfel încât coloanele să formeze
o bază ortonormală. Acesta va fi un fapt destul de
util pe care să îl avem la dispoziție.
Și încă un subiect pentru
această secțiune a lecției este noțiunea de proiecție.
O matrice pătratică Pi este
numită proiecție sau matrice de proiecție dacă cele două proprietăți care
sunt enumerate aici sunt ambele adevărate.
Acesta este un Pi majuscul, de altfel, este o alegere destul de tipică pentru o literă folosită pentru a denota o proiecție.
Adesea dăm aceste nume tipice obiectelor cum ar fi matricele, doar pentru a le face mai ușor de recunoscut și pentru a ține lucrurile organizate,
dar poți folosi orice nume dorești. Oricum, prima condiție este că Pi este egal cu propria sa transpusă conjugată.
În general, când avem o matrice care este egală cu propria sa
transpusă conjugată, spunem că este o matrice Hermitică.
Deci prima condiție poate fi formulată alternativ ca Pi este Hermitică.
A doua condiție este
că dacă ridicăm Pi la pătrat, adică înmulțim Pi
cu el însuși, obținem din nou Pi.
Deci ridicarea la pătrat a lui Pi nu face nimic.
Ideea unei proiecții
intuitiv vorbind este că este similară în
spirit cu proiectarea unei imagini pe un ecran sau cu coborârea unei perpendiculare pe o linie,
de exemplu. Când înmulțești un
vector cu o proiecție, ceea ce faci este în un anumit sens
să lași o parte din el neschimbată
și să anulezi restul.
Deci dacă aplici o
proiecție a doua oară, nu face nimic deoarece
ai anulat deja partea pe care proiecția o anulează.
Un exemplu de proiecție
este această matrice de aici pentru orice alegere a unui vector unitar Psi.
Putem verifica că satisface
condițiile necesare una câte una.
Pentru prima, calculăm
transpusa conjugată și aceasta este transpusa conjugată a unui produs.
Și deci putem folosi această formulă de aici pentru transpusa conjugată
a unui produs pentru a ne ajuta.
Ceea ce obții este produsul
transpuselor conjugate, dar ordinea se inversează.
Asta se întâmplă din cauza
părții de transpoziție.
Deci dacă aplicăm acea formulă, obținem această egalitate de aici și apoi putem simplifica pentru
a obține din nou matricea originală.
Observă, de altfel, că nu am folosit faptul
că Psi este un vector unitar.
Deci de fapt, această matrice este
Hermitică pentru orice vector Psi, nu doar pentru vectorii unitari.
Iar pentru a doua, ridicăm Pi la pătrat și obținem
această expresie de aici și aceasta este egală cu
matricea originală de această dată
deoarece Psi este un vector unitar, deci acest produs intern
de aici este egal cu unu, și acolo intervine presupunerea
că Psi este un vector unitar.
Aceasta este unde intră în joc.
Putem generaliza acest exemplu și pornim de la un set ortonormal.
Și dacă formăm această matrice de aici, unde sumăm proiecțiile corespunzând vectorilor individuali, obținem o proiecție.
Aici pe ecran poți vedea calculele care dezvăluie asta și îți las ție să
le examinezi dacă dorești.
Și în linii similare
cu primul exemplu, în a doua condiție se folosește ortonormalitatea
setului.
Ceea ce face această proiecție dacă
o înmulțești cu un vector, este să proiecteze acel
vector pe subspațiul generat de acest set de vectori,
ceea ce în mod abstract este
ca și cum ai coborî o perpendiculară pe acel subspațiu, și odată
ce ești în acel subspațiu, proiecția nu mai face nimic.
Deci matrice ca aceasta sunt
exemple de proiecții, și acum de fapt am epuizat
toate posibilitățile.
Fiecare matrice de proiecție ia această formă pentru o anumită alegere a unui set ortonormal.
Matricea zero este o proiecție, deci trebuie
să ne asigurăm că o includem dacă vrem să obținem fiecare proiecție.
WEBVTT
Deci, pentru a fi clar despre asta, permitem
posibilitatea că M este egal cu zero, și asta ne dă o sumă vidă,
pe care o putem interpreta ca matricea zero.
Acum că avem
conceptul de proiecție la dispoziție, putem defini o clasă mai generală
de măsurători cuantice cunoscute drept măsurători proiective.
Aceasta nu este noțiunea cea mai generală de măsurătoare, dar este semnificativ mai generală decât măsurătorile în baza standard
și va fi foarte
utilă să o incorporăm în descrierea noastră
a informației cuantice.
O măsurătoare proiectivă este definită de orice set de proiecții
care satisface condiția pe care o vezi chiar aici, adică proiecțiile
sumate dau matricea identitate.
Aici M poate fi orice
număr întreg pozitiv dorești, atâta timp cât acestea sunt toate proiecții și această condiție este adevărată,
colecția definește o
măsurătoare proiectivă.
Măsurătoarea descrisă
de o astfel de colecție funcționează în felul următor când
măsori orice stare cuantică Psi.
Mai întâi obții un rezultat
între unu și M, unde M este numărul de proiecții.
Pentru fiecare rezultat posibil, K, probabilitatea de a obține acel rezultat este norma euclidiană
la pătrat a vectorului pe care îl obții
înmulțind S cu Pi
K, proiecția a K-a.
Putem, de asemenea, scrie aceasta
cantitate cum o vezi chiar aici.
Această egalitate provine din relația dintre norma euclidiană
și produsul intern, împreună cu faptul
că Pi K este o proiecție.
Din a doua formă, împreună cu condiția pe care o avem pe aceste proiecții, putem vedea imediat, prin liniaritate, că probabilitățile noastre
vor fi întotdeauna sumă la unu,
ținând cont că Psi
trebuie să fie un vector unitar.
Și în al doilea rând, presupunând că
obținem rezultatul, K, starea sistemului
colapsează la starea cuantică pe care o obținem normalizând orice
vector obținem prin proiectare.
Vom analiza câteva
exemple imediat, dar înainte de a face asta, lasă-mă să menționez că de fapt nu avem nevoie
să numerotăm rezultatele posibile
de la unu la M. Putem alege orice nume sau simboluri vrem pentru rezultate.
În special, dacă avem o colecție de proiecții etichetate cu simboluri
dintr-un set gamma, să spunem,
și satisfac
aceeași condiție ca înainte, adică sumează
la matricea identitate, atunci avem o măsurătoare proiectivă
care funcționează exact
la fel ca înainte.
Singura diferență aici este că permitem
rezultatele măsurătorii să fie elemente ale acestui set gamma spre deosebire de numerele întregi de la unu la M.
Pentru primul nostru exemplu de
măsurătoare proiectivă, să observăm că
măsurătorile în baza standard sunt măsurători proiective.
În acest caz, setul de
rezultate ale măsurătorii este același ca setul de stări clasice ale oricărui sistem care este măsurat.
Iar setul de proiecții
care descrie măsurătoarea este această colecție de aici, presupunând că sigma este
mulțimea stărilor clasice
ale sistemului nostru. Acestea sunt toate proiecții
și dacă le sumăm, obținem matricea identitate, deci este o măsurătoare proiectivă validă
Pentru a vedea cum funcționează asta
în puțin mai mult detaliu, să presupunem că
avem o stare arbitrară scrisă în forma
pe care o vezi chiar aici.
Probabilitatea ca
măsurătoarea să dea rezultatul A, conform descrierii
de acum un moment, este această valoare de aici,
care este egală cu
valoarea absolută la pătrat a componentei corespunzătoare
a vectorului Psi, ceea ce era de așteptat.
Condiționată de rezultatul A, starea sistemului devine aceasta, tot conform descrierii
de acum un moment.
Dacă simplificăm, nu
obținem exact starea așteptată, care este Ket A.
În schimb obținem Ket A
înmulțit cu un scalar, și mai precis, acesta este un scalar cu
valoarea absolută egală cu unu,
deci este un număr complex
pe cercul unitate.
Acesta se numește fază globală și vom discuta fazele globale în curând, dar pe scurt deocamdată, această
stare este echivalentă cu Ket A.
Această fază globală nu
are de fapt nicio semnificație și vom vedea de ce
când ajungem la discuția despre fazele globale.
Deci (neclar), această problemă a fazelor globale, despre care vom vorbi imediat, vedem că măsurătorile în baza standard
sunt de fapt măsurători proiective. Pentru un alt exemplu, care este de fapt o extensie
a exemplului anterior,
dacă efectuăm o măsurătoare în baza standard
pe un sistem X și nu facem nimic sistemului Y, exact cum am discutat
în lecția anterioară,
este complet echivalent
cu a măsura sistemul X, Y.
Cu această măsurătoare proiectivă
chiar aici.
Avem aceste proiecții corespunzând stărilor clasice ale lui X și tensorăm cu identitatea pe Y
ceea ce reflectă faptul că
nu facem nimic lui Y.
Descrierea pentru modul în care
funcționează în general măsurătorile proiective ne spune
ce se întâmplă în acest exemplu, și îți las ție
să verifici că asta este de fapt
complet echivalent cu ce am discutat în lecția anterioară.
Asta este foarte frumos deoarece această descriere a măsurătorii proiective este mai curată într-un fel și vedem că se încadrează în
această imagine mai generală.
WEBVTT
Iată încă un exemplu de
măsurătoare proiectivă.
Acesta este o măsurătoare a două qubit-uri.
Pentru această măsurătoare
avem două proiecții și, prin urmare, două posibile
rezultate care sunt zero și unu.
Proiecțiile sunt definite
în termenii stărilor Bell, cum o vezi chiar aici.
Prima proiecție este
pe spațiul generat de cele trei stări Bell simetrice, iar a doua proiecție este
pe spațiul unidimensional
generat de starea Psi-, care este cea antisimetrică, sau cu alte cuvinte cea
care se înmulțește
cu un semn minus dacă
efectuăm o operație swap pe cele două qubit-uri.
Vom vedea mai târziu în serie de ce aceasta este o măsurătoare interesantă.
Deocamdată, este doar un exemplu
care se conectează cu ceva ce am văzut înainte,
și anume baza Bell.
O ultimă notă despre măsurătorile proiective este că de câte ori ai
o măsurătoare proiectivă, poți întotdeauna implementa acea măsurătoare
folosind operații unitare și
măsurători în baza standard.
Pentru acest exemplu particular de
măsurătoare, de exemplu, putem construi un circuit cuantic care implementează măsurătoarea
cum o vezi chiar aici.
Imaginează-ți că primele
două qubit-uri sunt qubit-urile pe care le măsurăm cu
această măsurătoare proiectivă, și ce putem face este
să introducem un nou qubit
care pornește inițializat
la starea zero. Efectuăm un gate Hadamard
urmat de un gate Fredkin, urmat de un alt gate Hadamard,
și dacă măsurăm acest qubit de jos cu o măsurătoare în baza standard, efectul va fi exact același ca și cum am măsurat primele două qubit-uri
cu măsurătoarea proiectivă
din acest exemplu.
Vom obține exact aceleași probabilități pentru cele două rezultate, iar efectul pe care măsurătoarea îl are asupra primelor două qubit-uri
va fi același de asemenea.
Asta nu este deloc evident. Este necesară o analiză pentru a vedea asta și analiza nu este prezentată aici.
Cum am sugerat deja, vom analiza mai îndeaproape
această măsurătoare particulară într-o lecție ulterioară și deocamdată
este doar un exemplu.
Punctul important de reținut este că ceva de genul acesta
este întotdeauna posibil pentru orice măsurătoare proiectivă, deci nu câștigăm cu adevărat
nicio capacitate suplimentară
introducând măsurători proiective, dar este un concept foarte util și vom vorbi adesea despre măsurători proiective
pe măsură ce continuăm în serie. Ultima parte a acestei lecții tratează câteva limitări importante
ale informației cuantice
și ce putem face cu circuit-urile cuantice.
Prima limitare, care poate nu este atât de mult o limitare cât o degenerare, privește problema fazelor globale
pe care am menționat-o cu puțin timp în urmă. Iată definiția a ce înțelegem când facem referire la o fază globală.
Dacă avem doi
vectori de stare cuantică, Psi și Phi, astfel încât unul dintre ei este
egal cu celălalt înmulțit cu un număr complex alpha,
atunci spunem că stările
diferă printr-o fază globală sau alternativ că sunt echivalente la o fază globală.
Observă că deoarece vectorii de stare cuantică au norma euclidiană egală cu unu, singura modalitate ca această
ecuație să poată fi adevărată
este dacă valoarea absolută
a acestui număr complex este egală cu unu, deci alpha
trebuie să se afle pe cercul unitate.
Să ne imaginăm că avem
două stări cuantice ca acestea care diferă printr-o fază globală și să presupunem că măsurăm starea Phi
cu o măsurătoare în baza standard.
Probabilitatea de a obține orice rezultat A este dată de această expresie de aici, și dacă substituim
alpha înmulțit cu Psi pentru Phi,
ceea ce putem face deoarece
presupunem că sunt egale, obținem această probabilitate.
Și dacă simplificăm folosind faptul că alpha se află pe
cercul unitate complex, obținem această probabilitate.
Ține minte că aceasta este probabilitatea ca măsurarea lui Phi să dea rezultatul A, dar acum vedem că
aceasta este exact aceeași cu probabilitatea ca măsurarea
lui Psi să dea rezultatul A,
deci nu există absolut
nicio diferență în probabilitățile diferitelor rezultate pentru cele două stări.
Un argument similar ne spune mai general că pentru orice măsurătoare proiectivă, probabilitățile sunt din nou identice.
Deci prin măsurare nu putem
distinge diferența între două stări care
diferă printr-o fază globală, nici măcar în sens statistic.
În final, dacă aplicăm orice operație unitară
stării Phi, atunci din nou prin substituție, ceea ce vom obține este exact
același număr complex alpha
înmulțit cu ceea ce am obține aplicând aceeași operație unitară
stării, Psi.
Deci cele două stări vor mai
diferi printr-o fază globală.
Concluzia este că cele două stări sunt complet indistinguibile, deci nu există nicio
diferență reală între ele
din punct de vedere a ce am putea
să aflăm despre ele efectuând operații unitare
și măsurători, și din acest motiv,
considerăm aceste două
stări ca echivalente, sau dacă preferi, că acestea sunt doar două posibil diferite
reprezentări vectoriale ale
aceleiași stări cuantice.
Cum am spus la
începutul discuției, este practic o degenerare
în modul în care stările cuantice sunt descrise de vectori de stare cuantică.
Oricum, ce înseamnă asta este că putem
pur și simplu ignora fazele globale, exact cum am făcut efectiv când am descris măsurătorile în baza standard
WEBVTT
ca măsurători proiective. De altfel, această degenerare apare doar în descrierea simplificată
a informației cuantice.
Când descriem stările cuantice
folosind matrice de densitate, cum vom face în
a treia unitate a seriei, vom avea o
reprezentare matriceală unică
pentru fiecare stare cuantică. Problema fazelor globale
pur și simplu nu apare în descrierea generală
a informației cuantice.
Este încă un aspect atractiv
al descrierii generale a informației cuantice,
la care tot fac aluzie, dar indiferent, fazele globale nu ne vor deranja
deoarece putem pur și simplu să ne exercităm
libertatea de a le ignora.
Iată un exemplu foarte rapid
doar pentru a ne asigura că noțiunea de fază globală este clară.
Dacă avem starea minus și minus unu înmulțit cu starea minus, atunci aceste două stări
diferă printr-o fază globală, și în particular avem
alpha egal cu minus unu.
Pe de altă parte, dacă avem starea plus și starea minus, atunci nu avem două stări
care diferă printr-o fază globală.
Aceștia sunt vectori ortogonali, deci sunt liniar independenți.
A spune că doi vectori de stare cuantică diferă printr-o fază globală
este echivalent cu a spune că vectorii sunt liniar dependenți,
deci cu siguranță acești vectori
nu diferă printr-o fază globală.
Este adevărat că singura diferență este că acest semn plus
se transformă în acest semn minus, dar asta se numește o diferență de fază relativă.
Asta este diferit de o fază globală deoarece nu
înmulțim întregul vector cu un număr complex.
Și asta este consistent cu faptul că putem distinge diferența
între aceste stări, în particular, dacă
aplicăm o operație Hadamard
și apoi măsurăm, vom vedea un zero dacă
starea era starea plus și un unu dacă starea era starea minus.
Următoarea limitare a informației cuantice pe care o vom vedea în această lecție
este teorema no-cloning.
Iată o formulare a
teoremei no-cloning și această formulare
particulară a teoremei este destul de concretă și specifică,
ceea ce va face mai ușor să vorbim despre ea. Există și alte modalități mai generale de a formula teorema no-cloning,
dar ne vom concentra pe aceasta deocamdată.
Presupunem că avem două sisteme X și Y care au aceeași mulțime de stări clasice.
care constă din
numerele întregi de la zero la D-1, unde D este cel puțin doi.
Nu este cu adevărat important cum se numesc stările clasice, dar alegând aceste nume ne va ajuta să simplificăm lucrurile.
Cel mai important
este că există cel puțin două stări clasice diferite, deci cu alte cuvinte, nu ne facem griji despre
cazul trivial și neinteresant
în care avem o singură stare clasică.
Ce spune teorema este că nu există nicio operație unitară U pe care o putem aplica lui X, Y, astfel încât dacă inițializăm
Y la starea zero,
să copiem sau clonăm efectiv
stări cuantice arbitrare ale lui X.
Dacă analizăm această
expresie de aici în mod izolat, ea spune că pentru toate alegerile unui vector de stare cuantică Psi al lui X,
aplicând U la Psi tensorat
cu starea zero, ne dă Psi tensor Psi, sau cu alte cuvinte două
copii independente ale lui Psi,
deci asta ar însemna dacă am putea clona stări
cuantice, și ce spune teorema este că acest lucru nu este posibil.
Te poți gândi la asta
în termenii circuit-urilor și ce spune teorema este
că nu vei putea niciodată să vii cu un gate sau un circuit
care funcționează cum vezi aici.
Unde o copie a stării Psi intră împreună cu o colecție
de qubit-uri inițializate și se produc două copii ale lui Psi.
Poți face asta pentru anumite
alegeri ale stării Psi, dar nu poți niciodată să vii cu
un circuit care funcționează astfel pentru orice stare cuantică Psi,
și asta spune teorema.
Este destul de ușor de dovedit
această teoremă, de fapt, se reduce esențial la faptul că transformarea pe care o
căutăm nu este liniară,
dar operațiile unitare sunt
liniare, deci pur și simplu nu poate funcționa.
Iată un argument în puțin mai mult detaliu.
Să presupunem că avem o operație unitară U care clonează stările
bazei standard, Ket 0 și Ket unu.
Știm că stările clasice
zero și unu trebuie să aparțină mulțimii noastre de stări clasice deoarece D este cel puțin doi.
Dar asta înseamnă prin liniaritate
că dacă X se află în starea plus, pe care o putem scrie astfel,
atunci rezultatul este această combinație liniară a acestor două stări de aici.
Cu toate acestea, acesta nu este comportamentul corect. Cerința față de U este că
U clonează starea plus,
ceea ce înseamnă că trebuie
să avem această ecuație de aici satisfăcută.
Aceste două stări nu sunt
la fel și deci nu funcționează, și asta este tot ce e de spus.
Câteva remarci suplimentare
despre teorema no-cloning.
În primul rând, această formulare a
teoremei no-cloning este absolută într-un anumit sens.
Pur și simplu spune că o operație unitară U care funcționează exact
astfel nu există.
Deci s-ar putea întreba dacă
există o operație unitară U care
face asta aproximativ, cu privire la un anumit mod de a descrie
WEBVTT
o aproximare a enunțului. Există diferite
noțiuni de aproximare care ar putea interesa
și vom vedea câteva
dintre ele în a treia unitate a seriei, dar pentru aceste diferite
noțiuni de aproximare,
există enunțuri cantitative
ale teoremei no-cloning care pun limite puternice asupra cât de bine poți clona aproximativ.
O a doua remarcă este că copierea sau clonarea stărilor bazei standard cu siguranță
este posibilă.
De exemplu, un gate Controlled NOT copiază stările bazei standard ale unui qubit.
Asta nu contrazice
teorema no-cloning. Ideea este că clonarea în sensul teoremei no-cloning cere
ca asta să funcționeze nu numai
pentru stările bazei standard
ci pentru toate stările.
Un gate Controlled NOT
cu siguranță nu clonează starea plus, de exemplu.
Și în final, merită să subliniem că există și o teoremă no-cloning pentru
stările probabiliste.
Este doar ceva
despre care oamenii nu vorbesc sau nu le pasă.
Dacă cineva alege
aleator un bit, de exemplu, printr-o modalitate arbitrară de
a atribui probabilități celor două valori și
apoi îți dă acel bit,
bineînțeles că nu există nicio modalitate de a obține două eșantioane independente
ale acelui bit aleator.
Pur și simplu nu știi
care sunt probabilitățile.
Poți copia bitul exact cum un Controlled NOT
copiază stările bazei standard, dar asta nu este același lucru cu clonarea stării probabiliste.
Pur și simplu nu ai suficiente
informații pentru a face asta. Orice bit aleator ți-a fost dat nu îți spune care
erau probabilitățile.
Este doar un bit.
Imposibilitatea clonării
unei stări probabiliste urmează din exact același raționament ca în contextul cuantic.
Clonarea este un proces non-liniar, în timp ce operațiile probabiliste, la fel ca operațiile unitare, sunt liniare.
Oricum, nu este surprinzător
că nu putem clona o stare probabilistă și
cumva nu este la fel de interesant ca faptul că nu putem
clona o stare cuantică,
dar ideea este pur și simplu să observăm că acesta nu este un fenomen exclusiv
cuantic.
Ultima limitare
a informației cuantice pe care o vom discuta în această lecție este că nu este posibil
să discriminezi perfect
două stări cuantice care nu sunt ortogonale.
O altă modalitate de a spune asta
este că dacă două stări cuantice pot fi discriminate perfect, atunci trebuie să fie ortogonale.
Ce înțelegem când facem referire
la o discriminare perfectă a două stări cuantice, Psi și Phi, este că există un mod
de a le deosebi
fără nicio șansă de eroare.
În termenii modelului circuit cuantic, putem exprima asta cum
o vezi chiar aici pe ecran.
Avem o operație unitară U, care ar putea fi implementată
ca un circuit cuantic, sau ne putem gândi la U în mod abstract
ca o operație unitară
și ca intrare forțată U ia fie starea Psi, fie starea Phi
împreună cu un grup de qubit-uri inițializate, pe care le poți gândi ca qubit-uri de spațiu de lucru care ajută cumva în acest
proces de discriminare.
După ce U este aplicat, qubit-ul de sus este măsurat cu o măsurătoare în baza standard și iată
partea de discriminare perfectă.
Dacă starea de intrare era Psi, atunci măsurătoarea trebuie
să dea rezultatul zero, 100% din timp, și dacă
starea de intrare era Phi,
atunci măsurătoarea trebuie
să dea rezultatul unu, din nou cu probabilitate de 100%.
Nu este important care sunt
stările acestor altor qubit-uri după ce U a fost aplicat.
Singurul lucru care contează este acest un bit pe care îl obținem din măsurătoare, deoarece acesta este bitul care ne spune cu care dintre cele două stări am început.
Pentru unele alegeri ale stărilor, Psi și Phi, va fi posibil să efectuăm o discriminare perfectă ca
aceasta, iar pentru altele nu va fi.
Și ce vom observa este că
dacă este posibil să facem asta, atunci Psi și Phi trebuie
să fie stări ortogonale
și asta înseamnă că dacă Phi și
Psi nu sunt ortogonale, nu le poți discrimina perfect.
Deci să vedem de ce discriminarea perfectă implică ortogonalitate.
Vom începe scriind două ecuații care exprimă ce exprimă aceste
două diagrame.
Dacă ne gândim la starea cuantică pe care o obținem după ce aplicăm U la
un grup de qubit-uri inițializate împreună cu starea Psi,
vedem că trebuie
să aibă această formă de aici, unde Pi zero este un vector de stare cuantică care reprezintă starea
tuturor acestor qubit-uri
mai puțin cel de sus. Nu avem nicio informație
despre această stare cuantică, Pi zero, poate fi orice,
dar știm că întreaga
stare trebuie să arate astfel deoarece aceasta este singura
modalitate ca măsurătoarea să garanteze că dă
rezultatul zero, 100% din timp.
Și avem o ecuație analogă
pentru a doua.
De această dată, qubit-ul de sus
trebuie să fie în starea unu, iar similar cu Pi zero, starea
Pi unu poate fi orice.
Și pe lângă faptul că nu avem
informații despre Pi unu, nu știm nici nimic
despre relația dintre Pi zero și Pi unu.
Pentru tot ce știm, acestea sunt doar două
stări cuantice arbitrare.
WEBVTT
Ce putem face în continuare este
să înmulțim ambele laturi ale acestor ecuații pe
ambele laturi cu U dagger, adică transpusa conjugată a lui U.
Și dacă facem asta, obținem cele două ecuații
pe care le vezi chiar aici.
Folosim faptul că U dagger înmulțit cu U este matricea identitate.
De aceea nu vedem U sau U dagger în partea stângă a niciuneia dintre ecuații.
Și acum putem lua în considerare produsul intern dintre Psi și Phi.
Este același cu produsul intern
al lui Psi și Phi înmulțit cu produsul intern
al stării L zero cu ea însăși
deoarece produsul intern al
oricărei stări cu ea însăși este unu și asta include starea L zero.
Și acum dacă ne uităm la cele două ecuații, vedem că această expresie de aici este egală cu produsul intern al vectorilor
reprezentați de cele două ecuații. Și mai precis este produsul intern dintre
stânga ecuațiilor.
Deci putem la fel de bine
exprima acest produs intern ca produsul intern al vectorilor reprezentați de
stânga ecuațiilor,
deoarece stânga este
egală cu dreapta pentru ambele ecuații.
Deci obținem această expresie de aici, care este produsul intern
al celor două drepte ale ecuațiilor, sau echivalent,
este transpusa conjugată a primei înmulțite cu a doua.
U înmulțit cu U dagger este egal
cu matricea identitate, deoarece U este unitar și deci dispare.
Și putem simplifica puțin pentru a obține produsul
acestor produse interne.
Acum ține minte că nu știm nimic despre relația
dintre Pi zero și Pi unu, deci nu știm care
este produsul lor intern.
Este un mister pentru noi. Dar oricare ar fi, îl înmulțim cu produsul intern al lui Ket 0 și Ket unu, care este zero.
Deci rezultatul final este că
obținem valoarea zero, dar asta este ce am vrut să arătăm, produsul intern dintre
Psi și Phi este egal cu zero.
Deci cele două stări sunt ortogonale.
Deci nu te obosi să încerci
să discriminezi perfect două stări cuantice ne-ortogonale, pur și simplu nu poți.
Există o reciprocă a
enunțului pe care tocmai l-am dovedit, și anume că stările cuantice ortogonale pot întotdeauna fi discriminate perfect,
și acest lucru nu este prea greu
de văzut dacă folosim un fapt pe care l-am menționat mai devreme în lecție.
Mai precis, dacă Psi și
Phi sunt stări ortogonale, atunci un lucru pe care îl putem face este să alegem orice matrice unitară U
ale cărei prime două coloane
sunt cele două stări.
Știm că este întotdeauna
posibil să facem asta și nu contează
pentru această sarcină exact cum este aleasă această matrice unitară.
Singurul lucru important este că acestea sunt primele două coloane.
Nu avem nevoie de qubit-uri suplimentare. Dacă pur și simplu aplicăm U la
cele două stări posibile, vom obține aceste
două posibile rezultate.
Și dacă măsurăm qubit-ul de sus, care ține minte că este qubit-ul din dreapta, atunci vom obține un zero sau un unu
în funcție de starea cu care am început.
Alternativ, putem lua în considerare
o măsurătoare proiectivă cu rezultatele zero la unu
definite cum o vezi chiar aici.
în acest caz, măsurătoarea
depinde de fapt doar de Psi.
Această măsurătoare discriminează perfect
Psi de orice stare care este ortogonală față de Psi.
Dacă măsurăm Psi cu această măsurătoare proiectivă, atunci vom obține rezultatul
zero cu probabilitate unu, cum arată aceste ecuații.
Iar pentru orice stare Phi
care este ortogonală față de Psi, vom obține rezultatul
unu cu probabilitate unu.
Nu voi trece prin
detaliile acestor calcule, dar dacă ești interesat, te încurajez să treci prin
detalii pe cont propriu.
Și aceasta este sfârșitul lecției trei. Am acoperit mult
material în această lecție, inclusiv circuit-urile cuantice,
produse interne și ortonormalitate, proiecții și măsurători proiective, faptul că fazele globale nu contează,
teorema no-cloning și faptul că stările ne-ortogonale nu pot fi discriminate perfect, în timp ce stările ortogonale pot.
Sper că te vei alătura mie pentru
a patra lecție în curând, care este ultima lecție din
prima unitate a seriei.
În a patra lecție, vom vorbi despre trei
exemple foarte importante, teleportarea, codificarea supradensă,
și inegalitatea CHSH sau jocul CHSH, cum este uneori descris.
La revedere până atunci,